*musique*
Bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo.
Inédite, exclusive, impressionnante...
Insérer un adjectif un peu stylé qui l'a met en valeur maintenant :
*bruits de chouette*
Il y a quelques temps, j'ai fait une vidéo qui parlait d'actualités sur Youtube.
Je m'étais fait kiffer. Je vous avais dit que je voulais parler de ce que j'aime, de ce qui me plait et de différents sujets.
Aujourd'hui c'est l'introduction officielle de ce nouveau format,
qui va traiter d'actualités, de ce qui s'est passé sur le net,
c'est un format inédit, innovant !
Je suis un Dieu, tout le monde veut entendre mon avis
Alors c'est parti pour le premier....
"Y'A QUOI" *bruit de verre qui se casse*
Alors on commence aujourd'hui et dirigeons nous
vers notre premier sujet qui est plus tellement d'actu
mais il faut en parler parce qu'il y a deux trucs très intéressants
à propos de ça dont j'ai envie de parler
et comme j'étais énervé en tombant la dessus
*voix d'enfant aigu* Mais de quoi parles-tu Lucas ?
Attends, ça arrive !
Laisse moi gagner du temps pour avoir les 10 minutes de vidéo !
Laurent... Ruquier !
Le 19 janvier dernier, il a animé sa célèbre émission "On n'est pas couché"
dans laquelle il tue sur place littéralement les invités
*bruit de chargement de pistolet* Journalise : parce que vous allez pas faire des blagues sur Youtube tout le temps jveux dire c'est...
Laurent Ruquier : et vous etes meme deja vieille par rapport aux autres *bruit de pistolet qui tire*
Mais on y va quand même!
On la veut cette promo pour mettre en avant notre dernière création!
Et il avait comme invité d'honneur la nouvelle Miss France ! *écho avec le mot "France"
Vaimalama Chaves, Chave,...
Je sais pas comment on dit ce nom je m'excuse désolé
Comme à chaque début d'émission, Laurent Ruquier introduit qui sont les invités
Mais ce jour là, on sait pas ce qui lui prend, il craque son slip et il fait une double gaffe !
Même les gens les plus maladroits de ce monde n'avaient pas atteint un tel niveau de gafferie !
Ruquier : "Le taux de natalité, c'est comme les salaires, ils n'augmentent plus ! Il y a donc de moins en moins de naissances
et de plus en plus de visites sur Youporn, sur les réseaux sociaux et on regarde de plus en plus les séries sur Netflix.
Voila on a plus le temps de faire d'enfant en France."
*claquement de main* Le rapport ? Le rapport ? Le rapport ? Quel est le rapport ?
Il a relié le fait qu'il ait moins de naissance au fait que les gens vont sur Internet.
Et regarde des séries et films en streaming...
aaaah
Ruquier : "d'ailleurs, vous qui nous regardez en ce moment dans votre lit,
pour relancer la natalité, nous avons invité ce soir notre Miss France.
Cela devrait vous donner des idées. Voilà !"
*musique stressante et gémissements de Squeezie*
Je vous mets le traducteur : pour relancer la natalité, nous avons invité une femme su le plateau
que nous réduisons uniquement à l'état d'objet qui vous donne envie de b**ser
*clappements de mains*
*musique espagnol + clappements de mains*
Alors, il y a plusieurs choses qui me font très mal dans cet extrait.
La première, je viens de la dire.
Et la deuxième, c'est la réaction.
Cette détresse la plus totale. Elle reprend ses dires
*applaudissement* Miss France : ''relancer la natalité" Ruquier, dans le fond : "vous voulez être Maman ?"
Relancer la natalité ? Ce qui veut dire clairement : "mais qu'elle grosse merde viens-tu de dire ?"
Et Ruquier qui utilise la corde de secours et qui pose une question totalement hors sujet
*en prenant une voix chelou* vous voulez être Maman ?
Est-ce qu'un jour une femme arrivera sur un plateau télé et les gens ne font aucune remarque
sur sa vie perso ou sur son physique ?
Est-ce qu'un jour ça arrivera
Même un banjo traiterai mieux une femme que Laurent Ruquier
*accords de banjo*
*claquements de mains* Ah bah on s'amuse avec ces petits effets tout ça hein !
Laurent Ruquier a fait ce qu'on appelle une Martin Solveig
qui après avoir remis la première récompense de l'histoire : le Ballon d'Or féminin, lui demande...
Martin Solveig : "est-ce que tu sais twerker ?" Ada Hegerberg : "nan"
*rire*
Toutes les réactions sont parfaites, aussi bien de la concernée que de Mbappé
qui est dans le public et qui a envie de dé-cé-der et de jouer à Fortnite
On peut dire : est-ce que l'audience à fait une Mbappé ?
Est-ce que dans le public dans On n'est pas couché à eu une réaction Mbappé ?
Peut-être !
*même extrait que tout à l'heure*
Mais la deuxième chose qui me gène c'est ce petit tacle dans son intro
Il met sur le dos d'Internet et de Netflix le fait les gens fassent moins d'enfants
En quoi Internet et Netflix empêcheraient plus que la télé les gens de faire des enfants ?
Ah si ! Si j'ai !
Si
*voix robotisée féminine* Oui Lucas ?
Car la télé, c'est de la merde, on préfère faire l'amour.
Alors que ce qu'il y a sur Netflix et Internet c'est un peu plus palpitant et que du coup, on est plus plongé dedans.
*bruit de bisou* C'est tout pour moi ! C'était la remarque objective de la vidéo !
Ahh! Une Bombe à eau on en est la une Bombe à eau, ok psychologies.com mais moi c'est quoi le rapport,!!